what was it about these reports in
particular that stood out because i'm
sure there are many reports by many
religious people about extraordinary
events so was there something in
particular or are you studying any
abnormal aberration from reality
no at this at this point i was just
focused on what happened to the practice
the catholic doctrine and practice of
purgatory you know prior to the 1960s uh
you could go to any catholic church and
there would be a place where you would
pray for souls in purgatory and that's
just not the case now and in fact if you
asked your friends who are catholic you
know hey what about purgatory they
wouldn't know what you were talking
about so i was looking at what why did
this dogma disappear basically and so
when i was i was looking at these
reports i would come to reports of
basically here's here's one that i had
in my book on purgatory it was in the
1800s and it was this nun in france and
she would continually see
an orb of light come through penetrate
her cell wall where you know she lived
and basically kind of hang out you know
i thought you met her cell walls
how could she see that oh my gosh this
is truly that would be really weird yeah
no where she was she was in a convent
and so this ball of light would come and
she was afraid of it and she'd tell the
people in her convent and nobody really
believed her first then finally
the mother superior came and stayed the
night in her you know room and
she saw also so they interpreted this as
a soul from purgatory and then they did
it they prayed it away they tried to
pray it away and so these are the kinds
of reports that i was identifying in all
of these these um you know lots of
different like chronicles you know these
kinds of sources it was unsuccessful
they're praying away was their prayer
unsuccessful and that's a good question
was it it apparently was
so was successful or unsuccessful it
appears to be because there was no more
report okay so i assumed that it was
successful
i think
yeah
so okay so um
yeah
so i had a list of these things and i
didn't include them in my purgatory book
just one or two of them because i
thought well the frameworks are so
strange for you know how people
interpreted these things
and i didn't quite understand what to do
with this big list of reports
so i was going to move on to another
book
and i happened to show a friend of mine
these reports and i said what do you
think of this stuff and the friend
looked at them and said they look like
steven spielberg movies you know like
ufos and i i thought that's crazy um it
just so happened that there was a
uh in my town there was a ufo conference
so i went to the conference and i
listened to people who had experiences
with aerial phenomena and the
inhabitants of aerial phenomenon
allegedly right and so it sounded so
much like what i've been studying that i
decided to turn my attention to
making kind of like this comparison
which is not you're not supposed to do
it in my field but i did it anyway i
wanted to see if there was kind of this
continuity between these reports from
historic you know history back at least
catholic history to today
and that's how i started now of course
the book became completely
different than i had intended um
so
that's how i started now the book itself
what happened when i got into the
research was that i didn't just find out
information about people who had these
experiences i also found out that there
were secret programs that our government
was engaged in this is before it came
out in the new york times and i met them
and i followed them around and they they
actually invited me on you know
excursions like to new mexico uh to find
debris from crash saucers and things
like that i mean it was pretty wacky i
thought it was really strange and i was
still an atheist when i was writing
the book it was until the very end this
took me a few years right it took me
years to get through
and we're now in 2022. um in 2019 the
book was published it was done in late
2017
and so how many years is that that's
like you know six years of my life that
i spent
and during that time period i went from
moving from an atheist
and a scoffer
to
what the heck is going on here agnostic